want to let you know about a shocking
new twist in a major gymnastics abuse
investigation a former u.s
olympics coach died by suicide just
hours after being charged with
24 felonies including human trafficking
and criminal sexual conduct john geddart
was head coach of the 2012 u.s women's
olympic gymnastics team
which won a gold medal he has one
himself or had
he had ties to disgraced sports doctor
larry nassar who treated gymnast
at get arts gym molalengi looks now at
calls
continued calls for more accountability
in the sport mola good morning to you
good morning tony getter once a
celebrated coach in the sport was
accused of mistreating
young gymnasts and lying to
investigators about
ever hearing of larry nasser's sexual
abuse
now for many including one survivor we
spoke to gedard's death is forcing them
to relive their trauma
yet again john
broke little girls he broke our spirits
and he
broke our bodies at eight years old
sarah klein began taking gymnastics from
coach john getter
she was the first known victim of larry
nasser but she says the physical
verbal and emotional abuse getard
allegedly inflicted
was far worse larry was at least
kind he was loving
he pretended at least to care about us
and john was the one
who tortured us in a way that it makes
larry and his sexual abuse look like a
walk in the park
getter was expected to turn himself in
thursday instead
authorities found his body at this
michigan rest stop according to cbs
affiliate wlns
he died from a self-inflicted gunshot
wound the michigan attorney general's
office called his death
a tragic end to a tragic story for
everyone involved it felt like
true to john getter form
i am above the law i am a narcissist
and i'm getting the last word i'm doing
klein an attorney john manley who has
represented more than 200 nassar victims
want usa gymnastics in the u.s olympic
and paralympic committee
to be held accountable for the abuse
these people
let this happen with nassar and getter
for money that's why this happened
in a recent interview with 60 minutes
olympian simone biles called for an
independent investigation into usa
gymnastics and the u.s olympic committee
to find out who knew what and when
we bring the medals we do our part you
can't do your part in return it's just
like
it's sickening klein agrees and said she
believes there is still abuse
going on in usa gymnastics what you can
do
is tell the truth give us the answers
help us understand how this could have
happened to us
do the right thing we asked usa
gymnastics
this morning to respond to klein's
claims but have not heard back
but in a statement last night the
organization said that it had hoped
criminal charges against getter would
lead to justice and that their thoughts
are with the gymnastics community we
also reached out to the us olympic
committee
and have yet to hear back from them a
spokesperson for the michigan attorney
general's office
said that they were allowing getter to
turn himself in on his own
because they had no indication that he
would harm himself tony all right
thank you very much there's a lot that's
upsetting here but one thing that comes
to mind is that the victims will not
have an opportunity for that public
justice and closure they got with nassar
and still they're still looking for a
lot more transparency from from the
gymnastics
community than they're getting yeah most
people in the public hadn't heard the
name
get it but they certainly knew and it's
sad tony they came up in the testimony
it did when when the victims came to the
microphone to speak
at nassar's trial they often brought up
that's when i heard it that's when i
heard it but no closure still
hurts a lot